[Applause]
but it feels good and it feels good
offensive
special teams that's how it goes man you
got me my mom hey
feels good so enjoy it enjoy this thing
when i just get done saying we are not
done you got me sir if you're done just
leave matt nagy coach of the chicago
bears that's funny if you're done just
leave we're not done
they have one congratulations to matt
neggie and the chicago bears they have
won the nfc north
a team that we all took seriously from
the moment khalil mack walked onto the
field this year even though they lost
week one to the packers we knew there
was something different about this bears
team they handled the seahawks monday
night football the following week they
really haven't looked back i think what
will happen though is they will look
back with regret at some of the games
they lost that they could have won
because they could have been yes the
number one seed and they could have
forced teams to come to the soldier the
rams the saints the seahawks think about
games that they blew against the
dolphins where they were kind of
controlling the game week one back to
the packers right i mean that's another
game they're gonna look at the giants
game two weeks ago where yeah it was
chase daniels and it was ugly on offense
and they blew that but you're exactly
right i mean they could be the one seed
or at least the two seed at the very
least i see a weird sort of parallel
back to 1984 when the bears went on the
road and lost to the 49ers in the
playoffs and that gave them i remember
seeing whether it was walter payton or
somebody else from that team on the way
home after that game they developed the
determination that they were going to be
the one seed the next year right because
they understand the importance now of
playing playoff games at home and the
soldier field home field advantage yes
is so great
we don't we don't realize it because the
bears are so rarely relevant they're so
rarely playing playoff games at all much
less playing them at home and i think
they're going to get a taste of at least
one this year as the three seed they
still have a chance that they're going
to be the two seed and
i think they'll know next year the goal
is be the one seed and take full
advantage of a real home field advantage
chicago in january yeah i mean it is an
extremely tough place to play by the
lake longer grass their team is built to
play that style of football all right so
you're right we'll see how this year
plays out
they're still they could still go to the
super bowl with that defense the way
what we saw them do to the rams two
weeks ago i think they can match up with
any offense they could slow down you
know drew brees and company i'd probably
pick the saints to win in new orleans of
course but it's not a given that's for
sure with the style of play nagi's
offensive schematics and everything he
can bring to the table in that defense
the bears are
a definite super bowl threat a couple of
road games to end the season though at
the 49ers and at the vikings and they
may get to week 17 and really not be
playing anything although that door is
still cracked for the number two see
we'll take a closer look at the nfc
playoff picture right after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports